you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays
a lot of attention to latin america one
of the least covered regions
in the world perhaps that is why many of
you have often asked us
to talk more about latin america despite
the way i butcher spanish names
well we have a solution
[Music]
we're proud to present latam politik a
newsletter that we have prepared
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you will receive 12
newsletters with the best
information and analysis on latin
america to keep you up to date and
better understand
everything that is happening in the
region the cost you can subscribe for
less than 35 cents per newsletter
less than a small taco or donut a week
in return
you'll be kept up to date on all the
major happenings in the region
and better understand all the possible
implications
in addition all of you who support us at
patreon level 4
and 5 will receive latin politic at zero
cost you can find all the info at
[Applause]
[Music]
latampolitik.com
the 14th of february 2021 carlos saul
menem who was president of argentina for
two terms passed away at the age of 90.
we are talking about one of the most
controversial figures in argentine
politics there is no middle ground
depending on who you talk to they either
idolize him or
demonize him
um
was a politician to the core one of
those social leaders who liked to be
surrounded by famous people such as
sportsmen artists and models and also
who had no qualms about saying one thing
and then doing the complete opposite
it is not known how much time will pass
how much blood will be shed but our
territory
malvinas will return to the people
carlos
february 14th 1989 one year before
resuming relations with the united
kingdom basically a perfect politician
this was a strategy that somehow served
him both for winning elections
and for making enemies for 10 years
between 1989 and 1999 he was president
of argentina and friends i can assure
you this was a really intense period his
liberal reforms and that multiple
accusations of corruption gave shape to
a period that some have called
the time when argentina wanted to change
but who exactly was carlos salman and
how did he change argentina why did the
reforms he promoted not hold up over
time did he really have a plan to stop
the doomed trend towards collapse that
argentina has been following for more
than 70 years if you're interested
listen up look of a leader
carlos menon was born in anilako a small
town in the argentine province of
loudoua on the second
of july 1913. he was the son of syrian
immigrants when syria still belonged to
the turkish empire throughout his life
he was in fact known as the turkish
menem from a very young age he had a
clear inclination for politics being a
militant in the pyrones movement a
movement that became forbidden after the
fall of juan domingo perron in 1955
almost 20 years later when democracy
returned in 1973 along with the return
of perron to the presidency menem was
elected governor of the la
rioja region a position he held until
the 24th of march 1976 when a new
military coup took place from that
moment on our protagonist men
as had happened to so many others had to
go from prison to prison a thorny issue
as we shall see because one of the most
controversial
and criticized measures he took when he
was president was precisely that of
pardoning the military chiefs of the
dictatorship what many do not know is
that he himself
was a victim of that dictatorship
[Music]
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
after the return of democracy in 1983
menem was again elected governor of la
rioja a position he held until 1989 when
he resigned to occupy the presidential
seat at that time in the 1980s menem was
seen as a strange character when the
term populism was not yet in vogue menem
was already a populist he claimed to be
a staunch nationalist he demanded the
recovery of the malvenas and defended
the fight against imperialism his image
was even compared to that of a ryojin
cordillo of 1829 fakundo corriga
of course as he made his way into the
upper echelons of national power those
exaggerated sideburns gradually
diminished until they disappeared
completely which
i can relate to friends believe me when
i tell you that carlos saw menim's
turnaround as president
still causes perplexity check this out
[Music]
from the minimobile
in 1988 the period of president raul
alfonson came to an end after a
complicated and convulsive mandate
characterized by the threat of military
uprisings the confrontation with the
pironis trade unions a bad economic
situation even resulting in
hyperinflation during its final years
everything seemed to indicate that the
successive president would be from the
main opposition party the parones party
so the dispute the great electoral
dispute took place precisely within this
party to win the candidacy initially the
great favorite was antonio caffero a guy
who just a year before in 1987 had won
the governorship of the province of
buenos aires the richest and most
populated province in the country
however my friends on this occasion for
the first and only time in the history
of the peronas party internal elections
equivalent to primaries were held to
choose the party's candidate
for the 1989 presidential elections and
as you can see my friends there was a
surprise
against all the odds menem defeated his
opponent by more than a hundred thousand
votes a new era was born the era of the
mena mistas
from that moment on our protagonists
began to tour every corner of the
country aboard the minemobile a bus from
which manem kept repeating over and over
again his emblematic campaign slogan
follow me
i will not let you down
[Applause]
during the campaign he promised all
sorts of things launching a productive
revolution general wage increases and
even recovering the falkland islands
with blood and fire who could resist
this new wave of hope
[Music]
although there were many who predicted
that was such a populace at the helm
argentina would end up looking more like
cuba than any other country it was clear
that at the time
no one could have imagined the great
turnaround that this politician was
going to bring about but this
is how he rose to the presidency
[Music]
pay attention to this last candidate
alvaro also from the union of the
democratic center when menem staged his
coup d'etat he became one of his main
advisers
sharp turn of the steering wheel
you see my friends in 1989 menem's
arrival at the casa rosada was not
exactly a bed of roses the economic
situation at that time was
chaotic which well in the case of
argentina i don't really think it's a
surprise to anyone we are after all
talking about the country of the eternal
crisis
it's been in crisis practically since
the late 1940s
the fact is that this president's first
month in office were not very different
from those of his predecessor 1989 ended
with an inflation rate of over three
thousand percent and in 1990 it exceeded
two thousand three hundred percent men
aims first twenty months in power were
as
erratic as those of his predecessor
however hold on one moment because
everything changed in 1991 when menem
revolutionized his cabinet by appointing
the then foreign minister domingo felipe
cavallo as minister of economy
from that moment on law 23696 on the
reform of the state which had been
approved as soon as he came to power
back in august 1989 but which had
nevertheless been on hold began to be
applied suddenly the country's economic
policy
and above all what had historically been
paroonism took a 180 degree turnaround
[Music]
the crisis hyperinflation and the
international context that was being
experienced with the fall of the soviet
union and the berlin wall seemed to make
it clear that argentina had no choice
but to change course and that is exactly
what today's protagonist carlos saul
menom did he brought to the table a
completely new concept in argentine
politics the popular market economy now
what exactly did this turnaround consist
of well basically it turned
the country upside down meaning a lot of
rolling up of sleeves getting down to
work on changing
everything or as we'll see almost
everything
but let's start at the beginning on the
27th of march 1991 the convertibility
law 23928 was passed which creates a new
currency to replace the austral the peso
four zeroes were eliminated so that ten
thousand australias became
one peso which in turn was convertible
into one us dollar in other words a
fixed parity was established to gain the
confidence of savers and
avoid the temptation to hit the banknote
printing machine as a result prices
began to
stabilize and inflation returned to a
normal level then
in october of that same year 1991 the
deregulatory decree 2284 was approved
which liberalized domestic and foreign
trade promoting the tax reform a capital
market reform and the transformation of
the pension system which became
private and that's not all
at the same time the economic
deregulation was promoted the government
launched a huge privatisation plan
during menem's first term alone the
argentine government privatised public
enterprises in telecommunications
gas water electricity railroads the post
office television radio airlines and
even arms production paradoxically
all the companies that per roon had
nationalized between 1946 and 1949 were
privatized by menem between 1992 and
1995. thanks to the majority support of
pironis deputies and senators that huge
wave of privatization together with all
the changes approved made foreign
capital flood into the country according
to data from indeck argentina's national
statistics and census institute foreign
direct investment rose from about 16
billion in 1992 to more than 65 billion
in 1999
[Music]
to give you an idea of how big this is
the argentine economy grew between 1991
and 1994 at a rate of 7 suddenly
prosperity had reached a destination
that seemed
impossible and with it came modernity
[Music]
take for example what happened in the
telecommunications industry until that
time it could take
decades for the public telephone company
intel to install a new line in a home
in fact houses that had a telephone cost
between 10 and 20
more than the houses did not because it
was so difficult to get one
that's crazy especially when you
consider we're talking about the 1980s
and the 1990s and not
1910 well the privatization of this
industry and the arrival of foreign
companies such as telefonica and telecom
italia fueled an enormous explosion in
the sector installing a new line became
a matter of a few days while mobile
communication and the fledgling internet
also arrived exactly the same thing
happened with electricity up to that
time
blackouts were frequent and even
programmed by the government itself
however with privatization blackouts
were reduced considerably while consumer
tariffs dropped by more than 24 percent
as you can imagine all these changes and
the economic growth that was taking
place improved the standard of living of
argentinians
and in fact the poverty rate dropped
from 47.3
in 1989 to less than half 22.2
in 1995
[Music]
[Applause]
but the changes were not linked
exclusively to the economy during
menem's first term in office with the
aim of consolidating democracy he also
promoted policies such as
national reconciliation by which he
pardoned all of the military and members
of guerilla groups who participated in
the dictatorship or the succession of
attacks in the country experienced
in the 1970s and the 1980s
[Music]
and so my friends this is how we arrive
at the second term of this politician
with an argentina that seemed to be
about to storm the world again
the pact of olivos
the first results of the reform plan
meant that the 1993 parliamentary
elections which were to renew one-third
of the senate and half of the chamber of
deputies peroneus candidates
swept the board the support mnem
received was so great that for the first
and only time in history peronism won
the city of buenos aires itself
[Music]
however wait a moment because there was
a problem at that time the argentine
constitution set a presidential term of
six years and forbade immediate
re-election in other words despite the
triumphant atmosphere and popular fervor
menem could not run
in the next elections and changing the
constitution was not an easy task it
required the support of two-thirds of
each house of congress and at that time
the opposition
led by the radical civic union and its
leader former president raul alfonson
was not in favor of it
so my friends what do you think the
argentine president did then well
nothing more and nothing less than carry
out a surprising political move you see
as he knew the majority of the
electorate was in favor of
constitutional reform he announced a
consultation a non-binding public vote
to tell the opposition come on
i dare you i dare you to oppose the will
of the people
what a queen's gambit check and mate
in 1994 carlos menem and rao alfonson
signed the pact of a levos which enabled
the constitutional reform that would
allow him to run for the election while
overhauling the election system each
presidential term was reduced from six
to four years and the electoral college
was eliminated to establish a direct
election in the second round
and that is how in 1995 manem was
re-elected by a
huge majority he simply swept the
elections however this new term was not
to prove as successful as the first
check this out
debt stagnation and poverty
everything seemed to be going smoothly
there was monetary stability inflation
was close to zero percent and
the growing commercial freedom had
opened up argentine's all the products
of the great storehouse that is the
global market
argentina seemed to be back on the front
line of international success and the
president surrounded by actresses
artists and athletes look like a rock
star but wait a minute my friends don't
pop the champagne bottle yet despite all
the changes there was one thing that was
never corrected
public spending and the enormous size of
the argentine state which had never
stopped growing
for a few years privatization revenues
paid a good chunk of the bills but then
the argentine government increased its
foreign debt
more and more to give you an idea when
men aim came to power argentina had a
debt of 63 billion dollars when he left
and in spite of all the income received
from privatization and economic growth
the public debt already amounted to 123
billion dollars the international
markets had trusted argentina but once
again the country had overextended
itself
in addition the fixed exchange rate with
the dollar kept the peso overvalued
which in the short term was for
argentine companies which still had to
face many rigid labor regulations and
additional effort that complicated their
international competitiveness
forcing a productive restructuring that
greatly affected industry
the system had a serious sustainability
problem on the one hand the state could
not stop spending without being able to
resort to the central bank on the other
hand maintaining a one-to-one
convertibility with a dollar was
achieved by supporting the peso which
consumes dollars that had to be financed
with
more issuing of foreign debt and to make
matters worse the one-to-one exchange
rate was causing readjustments in the
very economic sectors that had to
provide the dollars which meant
fewer dollars and more unemployment
followed by even more public spending
and so
back to square one the result a huge
house of cards and the reason one the
government did not want to tighten its
bill and two
it did not dare touch convertibility for
fear of huge capital flight and three
it never wanted to get involved in the
labor regulation and sure
maybe the argentine economy would have
worked without addressing one or two of
these issues but not with avoiding
all of them unemployment rose debt
skyrocketed poverty rebounded and
argentina's finances
began to collapse
as if that were not enough menem's
governments were also marred with many
shadows of corruption privatization had
been carried out but the subsequent
deregulation of the different sectors
was not fully executed perhaps because
the incentives pointed in another
direction there were many suspicions of
corruption yamagate arm smuggling
bonuses and hidden
envelopes it was nonstop as long as
things were going well society looked
the other way but when things began to
go wrong then menem's popularity began
to suffer when he approached the end of
his second and therefore final term and
wanted to maneuver again to run this
time
did not succeed in fact in the 1999
elections it was the opposition who won
the battle but the situation became so
problematic again
that in 2001 it was a run on the peso
that led to the collapse of 2001 and the
infamous corralito
[Music]
suddenly in a country where almost
everyone had been a men and supporter it
seemed as if
no one had ever supported him this was
the case for example of the kirchner
couple in spite of everything menem
tried running again
in 2003 and was the most voted candidate
in the first round however with no
chance of winning the second round
against nestor kirchner who had much
more support he decided to throw in the
let krichner keep his 22 percent i'll
keep my people i won the first round and
i'm leaving carlos
you see my friends my name has to be one
of the most charismatic politicians in
history in spite of coming to power in a
very difficult situation including
hyperinflation his first term in office
was almost a textbook success story and
for the first time in decades he
reawakened the argentine dream however
complacency and a failure to complete
his homework caused that dream to
eventually erupt in a violent explosion
that ultimately
doomed all of his reforms since then the
former president has spent a
large part of his life in court and if
he did not actually go to jail it was
only because of his immunity as a
senator a position he held until his
last day but now
having reached this point it's over to
you how do you assess carlos salmenim's
presidency where did you think he failed
did he follow a clear and pre-determined
plan or were the reforms simply a way of
buying time does argentina perhaps need
a new m like the one in the early 1990s
leave your comments below and if you
found this video interesting don't
forget to like it and subscribe to
visualpolitik and as always
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there
you